Hello. Good afternoon everyone. So, I am Dr. Plabun Kumar Bhomik and you will be having
with me Mr. Atil Varshan. So, both of us belong to the department of Artificial Intelligence
at Kharagpur. So, today we are going to talk about inference with pre-trained models. So,
let me talk about a cooking a bit before I proceed on to the topic. So, think about
your cooking say meat. I am really apologetic to the vegan people. But anyway, so let us
say we are cooking meat and when one way to do that is that you do the whole process marinate
etcetera etcetera. The other process you can follow that you boil the meat and steam it
and keep it somewhere and then you use that later to mix spices with that. And if you
go to the next the second process the benefit is that you will be requiring a very less
amount of time to prepare a dish right. So, of course we are not going to talk about cooking
today, but I think I will be talking about a very important recipe in the modern deep
learning or machine learning domain which we call as dealing with pre-trained models.
So, the topic that we are going to discuss is inference with pre-trained models. Now
whenever we talk about pre-trained models. So, that means something has that has already
been trained and if we try to think about how machine learning works. So, we have a
kind of model which we train with some data and we deploy that in the production setting
where we predict something we do some inference, but we are adding a kind of prefix we in terms
of pre. So, that means we do something prior to training and that is what we are going
to discuss right. So, the agenda for this module is. So, first we will be talking about
a very important connection between pre-training and transfer learning I guess the just last
lecture that was delivered today was about transfer learning and we will see that there
is a kind of very close connection between pre-training and transfer learning and we
will be talking about different pre-trained models in at least two domains one is vision
other is the language and finally, we will go into the inference with pre-trained models
what are the kind of inference tasks and what are the kind of recipes there and finally,
at if we will take you through this different kind of implementations and experimentation
with pre-trained models.
So, if we look at a typical machine learning workflow basically we are talking about supervised
machine learning. So, you need to have a set of annotated data set and you pick up a model
and train that data then that model with that annotated data set and finally, if you are
happy with the training accuracy and maybe the validation accuracy you will go to deploy
the model right. Now, if your model is very large that means the model has got large number
of parameters and by all means in the today's machine learning, deep learning or AI domain
most of the models are significantly large having large number of parameters and to avoid
overfitting we need to have large amount of annotated data set to train the model.
Now think about a scenario. Now whenever you are talking about training the model you need
to have this annotated data set that is a kind of prerequisite right. Now you have a kind
of abundance of data set. So, you think about social network every second you have thousands
or tens of thousands of posts in terms of text, video, audio and there are different
surveillance data in terms of video recording and there are online learning platforms where
you can track students behavior and as these online platforms are very popular nowadays
there are if you think about the data data is quite large. So, there is no scarcity of
data and they are available in different modalities. So, text, video, image, audio whatever you
can think about but as it comes in the terms of annotation of the large data set it is
really very challenging. First of all it is very costly you have to employ experts who
are kind of I mean conversant with that application area of the domain and of course it is time
consuming and it is not like that you get your data annotated by a single person and you
have to think about the reliability of the annotation because a single annotator may
be biased towards some annotation or a single annotator may not be error free. So, that
is why you want to get your data set annotated by multiple persons and then get an aggregated
annotation. So, but again you see that that is really costly and time consuming and that
is why perhaps we have less amount of annotation though we have huge amount of data in different
form. Now let us say for the sake of argument we assume that we have huge amount of annotated
data but even with that there are some challenges. Now whenever you have a big data and a large
model to train you need to have a very powerful computing facility and you see that this super
power computing facility is restricted to some big organizations like Google, Meta,
Microsoft and so forth. But majority of the AI community they do not have access to this
high compute facility. So, even though if you have large amount of annotated data you
may not be able to use it because of the lack of computation. Now in some cases how hard
you try you may not get large amount of annotated data and you always want your model to exhibit
out of distribution generalization. So, what do you mean by that? So, let us see your you
have trained your model with some data set and always we think that our test data would
be kind of picked up from the same distribution which has generated the training data. So,
theoretically that is ok but practically the test data may belong to a different distribution.
These two distributions may be overlapping but you may not guarantee you cannot guarantee
that they are coming from the same distribution. But in spite of that you want your model to
work good or better in the test data as well. But in some domains like say medical domain
let us say you want to record or do some task or perform some task taking as input the MRI
images of some cancer patients for example. Now you see there is a kind of it is a kind
of you cannot really get the data in a very large amount you cannot really collect the
data in large amount. So, the question is can we achieve generalization with limited
amount of data? Now whenever we train a model we always have a kind of assumption or goal
to have a model which is more general and pervasive and it will work for every setting
every individual. But you see every individual has got his or her own peculiarities and behavior
and ideally a person would want the model to work as per his or her own behavior. But
as you are training the model to be serving a kind of general purpose application or inference,
so this individual peculiarities may not be kind of tapped or individual behavior cannot
cannot be kind of model using this trained model. So, the question is let us say we have
a general model and can we use that to derive personal the models which can cater to the
personal needs. So, there comes the utility of this particular idea transfer learn.
So, let us say I have some general ideas about a particular domain and while I am training
a model I train the model to capture those general ideas of the concepts and whenever
I am trying to fine tune that to cater to the need of a very specific application then
we can somehow retrain it or fine tune it to solve this application specific or domain
specific trains. So, basically what we want to have we will
pre train a model and then we will use the feature representation of that pretend model
and using the feature representation we will try to derive another model which will solve
domain specific problems or applications. So, this is how the scenario looks like.
So, let us say we have a huge amount of data available to us. So, they may be annotated
or may not be annotated. So, this data set that you are taking looking at. So, let us
say they can be kind of image data sets where you have labels for each image or it can be
a kind of free text data where you do not have any specific label and with that we train
a backbone network. So, for example, I pick up say race net to be our backbone network
and we have a huge amount of image data and again as I told you earlier it may be labeled
or it may not be labeled. So, we just pre train the source model using
some training strategy which we will talk about later to derive a source model. And
of course, as we do not have any specific application in mind this source model basically
captures some general traits about the domain from which data has been picked up or collected.
Now, whatever knowledge that has been captured in this model that can be transferred to basically
if we think about in a very loose or maybe very lucid perspective. So, this we are copying
this model to form this target model. But as we want to capture very domain specific
trait. So, you will need to have some amount of data and again this data may not be very
large as we have done for this pre training part. We can use a very small amount of annotated
data and train this target model. And in that case we want this small amount of data to
be annotated. Now, you see we are kind of addressing the challenges that we have discussed
in the last few slides. So, it is addressing the challenges of like not having access to
large amount of annotated data. We need just need a very small amount of annotated data.
And again as we are training with small data it is not like that I will need a very powerful
computing facility right. And again I can really look at this personalized models if
we think about targeted data to be collected from the personal behavior or something like
that. So, this particular idea as you can see it is able to address the challenges that
we have or practical challenges that we have just mentioned few slides back. So, the left
hand side as we can see this is the part what we call as pre training. Here we do not have
any domain specific objective training objective in mind. But of course, as we are training
it we should have some objective and maybe we will be talking about those kinds of objective
training later. And the right side of it where we are using
a small amount of domain specific data and to derive this target model this is what we
call as adaptation. We are adapting an existing trained or pre trained model to fit to the
niche domain requirement. So, the general recipe for pre training is that first you
need to collect raw data and as we talked about earlier raw data is available in huge
amount in the form of web data, social media data and it will set some pre training objective.
So, this pre training objective can be supervised. So, for example if you are training your model
using image net data which has got huge amount of labeled images. So, there this pre training
objective can be supervised. But sometimes when the labels are not available then we
can use some technique what we call as self supervised training objective.
And the third thing that you need to find out which particular backbone model we will
be using to pre train. And there are plenty of options there as you know there are too
many architect architectures available and depending on the modality of the data you
can pick up image related architecture or vision related architecture or text related
architecture and sometimes some more general architectures like transformer.
So, let me talk about pre trained vision models. So, as I have given a very bird's eye view
of the requirements or the general recipe of pre training I am following that idea in
this slide as well. So, you need to have access to huge amount of data and this data is available
in vision domain in different forms from different organizations. So, image net is I think the
most popular image data set out there. So, there you have around 14 million images with
21000 object classes, 10 cent machine learning images, JFT 300 million image set, Facebook
Instagram image set. So, the point is there is a kind of huge amount of image data set
which you can make use to pre train some models. Now as the choice of the backbone network
one can make use of race net if someone wants to build a small models. So, it has got parameters
in the range of 25 million to 65 million and if you want to go further you can make use
of vision transformers. So, there are different options to pick up the backbone network which
can be pre trained. Now again as per as the training objectives
are concerned. So, if you are using image net you can make use of something some training
objective like supervised and sometimes if the label is not available you can make use
of self supervised techniques. So, there are other ideas while we are deriving this pre
trained model for vision modality. So, one such idea is mass auto encoder. So, here the
idea is you take an image and mask some of the regions and with the remaining region
you learn a feed that to an encoder, learner representation and the representation will
be fed to a decoder and the decoder will now try to reconstruct the masked region of the
image. Now in that way the network will find out
a very good representation it will be resilient to missing out some of the regions in the image.
And here you can see that we are not really using any label. So, I am not telling that
this image is an image of a parrot or pigeon. I am just giving the images input to the network
and we are just masking some regions. So, as we are not using any labels explicitly
this does not belong to the supervised strategy. Mostly it will belong to this self supervised
strategy where we are not using and you see this is not similar to unsupervised learning.
So, here we are using the supervision signal from the image itself. So, what is the supervision
signal this masked region they are our supervision signal. So, your representation will be good
if you can faithfully reconstruct the masked region. So, that is why we call it as self
supervised training. So, this Dino V2 is another popular architecture
which has made a very good innovation in curating the training data set. So, again you can have
a very less amount of curated data or a moderate amount of curated data, but or annotated data.
But what you have you have a large amount of unannotated data. So, what can be done?
One can learn some representation for all of these curated as well as uncurated images
using some architectures like say vision transformer. And then what we can do we can remove some
duplicates and why that is necessary. If we remove the duplicates then perhaps we can add
diversity to the training examples and that is very important you do not want your model
to be biased towards some segment of data. So, you have to diversify into multiple regions
or regions of different difference right. Now after this duplication, duplicate detection
has been done we can remove this duplicates and then we can take a curated data or image
for which we know the label and we can do a kind of similarity search to find out the
images which are similar to this input image for which the label is available and perhaps
assign this labels the same label to the retrieved images for which we did not have the label
earlier. So, in that way we can increase our data set to a larger volume and again we can
use a kind of any backbone network to retain our vision model.
Now as far as the languages are concerned, so we follow something called distributional
semantics. So, here our basic idea is that we want to somehow represent the basic units
of text and this basic units may be words or they may be some fragments of the words
which we call as sub words. But whatever it is we will understand the meaning of a word
if we know which are the other words this current word is co-occurring with. So, the
basic idea is that the meaning of a word is distributed into multiple words which are
co-occurring with the current word. So, that is what the basic hypothesis of this all these
language models.
So again we use a kind of self supervised technique to pretend this language model. So, what we
have with us we have with us a huge amount of text. So, they may be news articles they
may be Facebook post or whatever it is. Now we will pick up individual words and we will
try to find out what are the other words that are co-occurring with it. So, we will term
or designate a particular word to be the center word and the co-occurring word to be the
context word and we will try to learn a model where we try to maximize the probability of
the context word given the center word or we can look that in a reverse way also. So,
here we are putting the training objective to maximize the probability of seeing a context
word given the center word and this probability should be very high if a pair like a center
word and the context word is a valid pair. Now, we can take a kind of window based approach
where we will fix a window size let us say so, so basically what we are trying to maximize
we are maximizing maximizing the probability of seeing the context word given the center
word. Now, this will help us to learn the representation of the words and we can see
that this representation is reflected in this relationship between the pair of words.
So, for example, you can see that China and Beijing is related the same way the Russia
and Moscow are related. So, we can see that these vectors are really parallel to each
other the relationship they are really parallel to each other. So, not only that we can represent
this relationship we can also represent the grammatical relationship with this pretend
language model. But there are certain difficulties with this kind of learning. So, what are the
difficulties? So, let us say I have a kind of word apple and this word apple is may appear
in different context. So, it may appear in the context of gadgets branding or it may appear
in the context of say fruit or other different kind of context.
Now, while we are collecting the context we are merging different types of context while
we are trying to find out finding out thus the context word given the center word apple.
Now, as this different kind of context words are mixed up then we are having a single representation
of apple and that is not really good because it now we are really confused whenever I am
having a representation whether that representation is valid for the representation that needs
the apple brand to be representation represented or apple fruit to be represented. So, that
is why we talk about the other architecture which is really capturing this context and
this the first step toward this direction was this BRT. So, this is what we call as bi-directional
encoder representation through transformer. So, here we try to segregate the context in
which a particular token appears. Now, here we can have two different representation for
apple depending on the context in which it is appearing. If it is appearing in the context
of say branding or so, it is if it is appearing in the context of the apple company or something
like that. So, then the representation will be different than if it is appearing in the
context of fruit. So, here the idea is that we are looking at the left context and the
as well as the right side context of a token and we get a representation as we pass the
token through the layer and these are the kind of derived representation that we are
getting. Now, in this architecture we have a special
token which is what we call the CLS and that token is used to perform some prediction task
on this pretend model. And I think there are some other modules where this kind of architectures
will be dealt in detail. So, that is why I will not be going in depth with this architecture.
But what I like to talk about how to pretend this kind of language models. So, a very important
pretending objective that we set a strategy that we set what we call as must language
model and there we use something called 80-10-10 corruption. So, what is that? So, for taking
this corpora or text data training data with us, we will be picking up around 15 percent
of the tokens or words and out of this 15 percent we will be replacing 80 percent of
this 15 percent token with the token special token mask.
So, for example, if I have a kind of sentence heavy rain caused the flood, I will mask a
certain word like say rain with this token mask and we will want the model to predict
this mask token to be a correct token to be rain. Or what we can do? 10 percent time
we can replace this particular target word with a kind of random word. So, for example,
we can replace rain with cup or remaining 10 percent we can keep it unchanged. So, sometimes
we may not really want to change this particular token.
So, this is what we call as self-supervised pre-training in while we are training a language
model. So, there is another training objective or self-supervised training objective what
we call as next sentence prediction. So, again if you think about a training data, you can
think this as a sequence of sentences and you really do not have need to have explicit
annotation which sentence appears after which sentence and that comes for free that comes
automatically. So, what we can do? We can set a training objective like whether the model
can predict what would be the whether that for a pair of sentence whether the second
sentence is a is the next sentence for the first sentence.
So, as you can think of here we our input is the man went to the store to and the next
sentence he see bought a gallon of milk. Now, here you can see that we are kind of mixing
up two things one is next sentence prediction as well as a mass language model and what
we want to say that these two sentences they are a correct next sentence candidate. So,
I can say that he bought a gallon of milk is a correct next sentence for the sentence
are the man went to the store right. But the next example which says the man went
to the store and the coming up sentence is penguins are flightless birds and as you can
see the second sentence is not a natural next sentence for the first sentence and you can
see that this can be used as a supervision signal though we do not have explicitly annotated
data. So, if we mix these two training objectives together that means, the make mass language
model as well as next sentence pair prediction. So, the architecture will go like this or
the training process will go like this. So, we have the tokens for a sentence a and the
tokens for the sentence b and as you can see some of the tokens in sentence a can be massed
and some of the tokens in the sentence b can be massed and we pass these two sentences
through this BART architecture and then finally, we have the CLS level the representation for
the CLS level and we use that representation to predict whether this pair is a valid next
sentence pair or not and in some and whenever we have massed a particular token and for
that token we will output what would be the correct token for that right.
Now, it may be possible that you can pre train a model using a mixed modality. So, here we
can mix a vision as well as a language modality to come up with a pre training model which
can model both vision and language. So, here the pre training objective can be many. So,
for example, we have this image and we have some objects detected in the image and we
can design some task around this image. So, for example, I can have a task which is visual
question answering and here the question that we are asking what color is the child's
outfit. So, here the answer is orange. Now, we can feed this together to the model and
try to do a correct prediction that given this image and given the question what color
is the child's outfit and we should have the result to be or answer to be orange.
We can also design a task what we call as predicting the referring expressions or finding
out the referring expressions. So, what do you mean by that? So, again we have got different
objects in this image. So, we have a sheep, we have a child, we have a basket whatever
so and so forth and we have some linguistic expression or language expressions like child,
sheep, basket, people sitting on chair and we will try to align which token or which
phrase aligns to which object in the image. The third task that we can talk about what
we call as multimodal verification. Now, here we will be asking some question true false
question out of this image. So, for example, we are asking the child is petting a dog.
So, we are having a statement and we have to predict the truth value of the sentence.
So, here we are the correct truth value is false. So, you need to train your network
in such a way that it will predict for this given. So, here you see that the input to
this network is the image as well as the sentence or the sequence of tokens like the child is
petting a dog and your answer should be false a prediction should be false or we can think
about caption based image retrieval you can give a as query a string of or a phrase or
a sequence of words and as a result you would be able to retrieve the image which represents
that particular phrase or you can generate the caption of the image.
So, let say you are given with the image and you want to generate the caption in a phrase
or in a sentence manner. So, there have been quite a large amount of work in this vision
language models. So, for example, Facebook, Google, Microsoft, they have come up with
very efficient models in down the I mean starting from say 2019 and still this racing this going
on.
So, nowadays people talk about models like lava deep seek vision language model. So,
this open AI GPT V4. So, they are now having this multimodal capabilities as well. Now,
again for this kind of vision language model what kind of pre training objective we can
set right. So, here we are setting a pre training objective like so, we have this image and
we have this description we need to align these two. So, so, given this image we need
to come up with this description we should be able to generate this description. So,
this is a kind of training example which is put to the model.
Now, there might be different self supervision objective. So, one such self supervision objective
can be simply mass language model as we have seen earlier. So, what we are seeing here?
So, in this kind of model we are feeding the patches of the images and as well as the paired
sentence as we have seen in the training example. So, we have this image and this paired sentence
right. So, we are feeding both, but as you can see that we are masking some tokens in
the sentence and the pre training objective would be to predict this token correctly right.
Or else what we can do? We can mask some region in the image. So, these are the patches of
this image. Now, we are masking certain region of the image we are keeping this sentence
intact and we want to reconstruct the masked region. So, this is what we call as masked
region modeling. So, third thing what we can do? We can do kind
of image text matching. Now, as we are giving this image as well as the text associated
with that. Now, this pair can be a positive pair. So, for example, the pair what we have
seen earlier is a positive pair, but the pair that we are seeing in this example that the
bus is. So, now this text is talking about some bus related thing though we are talking
about a man with his dog on a couch. So, this is not a positive pair and it should be outputting
0 instead of 1. So, this is what we call as image text matching.
Now, while we are let us say we have done this pre training with all these three elements
in the recipe, accessing the data, finding out or choosing the architecture and fixing
the pre training objective and with that we pre train our model. Now, we will be talking
about how to make use of this pre trained model. Now, there are different ways we can
follow. So, the first strategy is that we have this pre trained model and we will be
freezing all the parameters. So, as we can see in the left hand side the blue region
all the parameters of this model they have been trained earlier with some data set and
training objective. Now, I want to use these to solve some problems related to a different
application domain having annotated data. So, what we can do? We can take out the final
layer representation of this pre trained model and feed that to a prediction head which can
be another architecture. So, let us say we have a kind of multilayer perceptron or kind
n number of layer network and what we do? We will be kind of fine tuning the parameter
of this model. We will be tuning the parameters of this particular part of the architecture
which is in the yellow part. And we will be optimizing the loss based on the limited data
set that is given to us. And we will be fixing the parameter of this part only leaving out
all the parameters that we are having in the blue part right.
So, this is one strategy. Now, the second strategy is we freeze some of the parameters
maybe in the very initial layers, but we leave the other parameters of this pre trained network
to be fine tuned. And along with that we have this prediction head network which will be
again fine tuned as well. So, here we are not really fine tuning the all the parameters
of the base model or the pre trained model. So, what is the kind of benefit of these two
kind of architectures. So, as you can see in the first strategy here. So, the number
of parameters that are needed to be tuned are very less. We are just looking at updating
the parameter of this part right. But in this remaining part this strategy 2 we are updating
a kind of more number of parameters than the strategy 1. So, we are updating the parameters
of this part as well as updating the parameters of this part right.
So, these are these two strategies have kind of advantages and disadvantages right. Now,
in the first strategy in the strategy 1 as we see that we have have less number of parameters
to tune. So, it will be converging faster right and may be it will take less amount
of compute right or the time to update the parameters would be pretty much low. But as
you can see here in the strategy 2 as the number of parameters that are to be tuned
has increased. So, you have to run it for longer epochs or longer time or train it for
longer time to converge that is one thing. The other thing is that as you are updating
many parameters or more parameters than the strategy 1. So, may be it will require more
compute power than the strategy 1 right. Now, why should we use strategy 2 then.
Now, think about a scenario where we are kind of we are not given with this pretend model
we are just given with this level data and someone tells me that well you train this
network from scratch. So, that is also kind of strategy I will just throw all the parameters
of the model I will train from the scratch. And if we train from the scratch perhaps it
will capture better the domain related integracies than freezing the entire model just updating
a few parameters. So, may be as it is capturing the domain related
structure very efficiently the training from the scratch model. So, there we might get
a better accuracy than the model where we are using a pretend model and fine tuning
a part of it or not even fine tuning the entire part right. So, now this strategy 2 is a kind
of middle ground. So, here we are not really throwing away all the parameters of the pretend
model we are leaving some space for the network to learn the domain related integracies.
But what we are making use of we are making use of representation of the initial layers
the question is how does that help. Now, think about an image related prediction
model and let us say we are training your model to classify birds right. Now, your initial
layer will try to learn very basic features like say edges there would be some edges in
the images. Now, if you go forward the then the next layer will be maybe it will be learning
the different shapes like circle or triangles one so forth. But as you are going forward
to the deeper layer they will be learning more abstract features which are very much
aligned to the domain for which you have used the training data.
Now, keeping these initial layers intact that means you are using lower level features and
this lower level features are very common to different applications. So, if you are
classifying birds you will be requiring a kind of edge detector and if you are classifying
the curves there also will be requiring edge level detectors or edge features. So, that
is why you can keep the initial layers intact we will not be updating the parameters. Now,
as this penultimate layers or the layers closer to the penultimate layer they are kind of
capturing the abstract and domain dependent feature. If we update them using domain dependent
data they will be capturing the domain related feature much better.
So, that is why we take a middle ground we do not train from scratch or we really do
not freeze all the parameters of the pretend model. So, we take a middle ground we keep
some parameters frozen for the pretend model and keep the remaining parameters which are
closer to the penultimate layer to be updatable or fine tunable.
Now, again we can take the final layer representation of the pretend model and put that in a prediction
head prediction network and with that we can perform different tasks like image classification,
object detection, semantic segmentations and so forth. So, as far as the pretend language
models are concerned we can make use of them to in different prediction tasks. So, for
example, we can use them to do some classification tasks that involves a sentence space. So,
for example, I want to detect whether two questions are paraphrases with respect to each
other or not or given a pair of sentence one being the premise other being the hypothesis
you want to check whether the premise or a hypothesis can be entailed by the premise
or not. So, these tasks are concerning a pair of
sentences and we want to classify again whether a pair of sentences are paraphrases or not
or in the natural language inference domain for a given pair whether they are a kind of
entailed pair or contradicting pair or they are neutral right or given a pair of sentences
whether they are semantically similar or not. So, the bottom line is that the input to the
network is a pair of sentences again we transform them into the tokens into the embeddings
and we pass this through a set of encoder layers which are kind of implemented via transformer
architecture and we have the final layer representation and we use the CLS token representation
and we feed that to another multi layer or a linear layer to predict the class level.
So, for example, for a paraphrase detection the class level might be yes it is a paraphrase
no it is not a paraphrase. Now there might be classification tasks which involve only
a single sentence as input. So, here we are trying to check whether a given sentence whether
that represents a positive emotion or a negative emotion. So, we can think about a task like
sentiment detection we can think about a task like a grammaticality of a sentence. So, given
a sentence as input we need to predict whether the sentence is grammatically correct or not.
So, this is what we call as the COLA task. So, again as we did earlier we will be passing
this single sentence tokenize it and then we get the embeddings of the individual tokens
and finally, we will be using the representation of the CLS token to predict whether it is
depicting a positive or negative or neutral emotion.
So, this prediction task may involve they may be in the token level. So, for example,
if we think about question answering task. So, here input is a question which is again
a sequence of tokens and a paragraph again a sequence of tokens and we need to predict
for this given question what are the tokens present in the paragraph which are the span
that we are marking is a potential answer to the question. So, here we can see that
our prediction would be in the token level. So, for example, this T 1 prime is the start
of the answer and say T m prime is the end of the answer.
We can think about solving this named entity recognition task where again the input is
a single sentence and we need to mark the token whether it is inside a named entity
or outside a named entity sequence. So, again we can talk about inference using
pretend vision language models. So, here for example, we are talking about visual question
answering we have again as input the image and question and using that we need to find
out the answer. So, for example, we are asking for this given image what color are her eyes
and your model should predict it to be black. So, there are other tasks in vision language
model. So, for example, we can think about a task like entailment. So, for example, given
this image we can state different facts. So, this is our premise in an inference or entailment
problem we have two sentence or two entities one is a premise other is the hypothesis.
And in this case we have the premise to be an image and we have different hypothesis
in the form of sentences. So, for example, we are saying that two women are holding packages.
So, here we need to predict that this is a correct entailment pair. So, that means this
is true given that premise is true or we can say that the sisters are hugging goodbye while
holding to go packages after just eating lunch. So, here we are saying that this is having
no way close relation or very tied or coherent relation with this image. So, we are marking
this as neutral or the third sentence the men are fighting outside a deli. So, this
is really a contradiction. So, given this image which is true we cannot say that this
sentence is true. So, the way to make an inference out of this.
So, what we have again we will be feeding these two as input the image and the sentence
and this should predict for the CLS token whether the CLS token can be classified into
entail neutral or contradict class. We can perform visual reasoning as well. So, for
example, we are given with a pair of images a left side image and the right side image
and the left side image we have got two dogs and the right side image we have got one dog.
Now, we are asking the left image contains twice the number of dogs as the right image
and at least two dogs in total are standing. So, here this result of the prediction would
be true. So, whatever that is there in the image the pair of images this particular sequence
of words are correctly capturing that. So, in that case the output should be true.
Now, here we are feeding one image the left side image along with the entire text in one
unit and the right side image and again the same text in the another unit and we will
pass these pairs at this individual units will be coming out coming up with the representation
of the CLS token and we have a kind of CLS token for the left hand side image and a CLS
token for the right hand side image we concatenate that and we predict either true or false.
So, again I think I have given a very brief overview of what we mean by pre-training and
what are the kind of recipe for pre-training to be done and how these pre-trained models
can be used in different modalities like text, vision and this multimodal setting. So, there
are a kind of huge amount of resources available. So, for example, for pre-trained vision model,
pre-trained language model, pre-trained vision language model now you see nowadays these pre-trained
models are pretty much abundant and I think hugging face is a very good framework or platform
where these pre-trained models are maintained quite elegantly and as you see nowadays we
are talking about small language models and what one can do download these pre-trained
language models and then fine tune this language models using small amount of annotated data.
So, I think I am done with the theory part and I guess we can go forward with the hand
transition and for that I would like to invite Artif. So, I think we will be having a break
for 5 minutes and then we will be going on with this hand transition. Thank you very much.